Dictator Muammar Gaddafi ruled Libya for more
than 40 years.
But when the end came - it was fast.
In 2011, the people rose up in mass protests.
Rebels killed Gaddafi.
The dictator was gone.
But the country has been in chaos ever since.
Fragmentation is the best single word to describe
what's happening in Libya.
A large number of actors and communities and
groups all effectively competing against each
other.
Militias, extremists and many international
powers are ripping the country apart.
And there are even two rival administrations,
each claiming they should be in control.
So how did things get so bad - and so complicated
- in Libya?
Let us unpack that for you.
First, let’s look at the bigger picture
- and what’s at stake.
Libya has a long coastline right at the doorstep
of the European Union.
That has made it a major stepping stone for
people looking for refuge or a better life
in the wealthy north.
The government chasm in Libya has enabled
the rapid growth of things like human smuggling
through the country.
We've seen, of course, that this can allow
a breeding ground for extremist groups.
Libya is also home to Africa’s biggest oil
reserves.
And THIS puts it on the radar of other countries.
Any disruption of the energy supply coming
from Libya is also important for Europe.
But also because it constitutes the door to
Africa to some extent.
So the country if the situation was better
could also play an important role as a platform
between Europe, Africa, the Middle East and
possibly further.
And most importantly - there are six million
Libyan people.
Desperate for a safe, secure future.
Thousands have been killed in the fighting,
hundreds of thousands have been displaced
from their homes, and more than a million
need humanitarian aid.
We can trace the roots of this situation all
the way back to 2011.
The popular protests known as the Arab Spring
swept through the region.
Dictators fell like dominos.
And Libya’s strongman Gaddafi was no exception.
But the way he’d ruled made Libya ill equipped
to get back on its feet.
what Gaddafi operationalised as a system…
is a divide and rule system to dilute the
relevance of anyone he would deem or any faction
he would deem potentially a political, military
opponent, either by purging them or kind of
marginalizing them from his patronage network.
He used both his tribal knowledge and his
tribal skills, but he also used religion as
well to control the population.
Once Gaddafi was gone, tribes and militias
which had united to get rid of him - turned
against each other.
In 2014, a disputed election plunged Libya
into the abyss.
Key civil institutions like law enforcement
and the judiciary collapsed.
But as we heard earlier, two rival administrations
emerged, both claiming to be the real, legitimate
government.
There is a legitimacy vacuum in Libya, and
all of the institutions or the governments
that exist today have had their mandates expire
a long time ago.
The only reason that these institutions or
these political classes or political leaders
exist today is because of circumstances, and
it's because of the failure of the democratic
transition.
What makes it even worse - the country sits
on the division line of a fundamental rivalry
that runs through the entire region.
The competition for power inside Libya between
domestic players extended more regionally
and internationally.
You could also see in this confrontation between
the two camps, two different models of power
competing in the post Arab Spring era.
A division between what was called at the
time, the Islamist camp versus the others
that could be described as nationalist, more
military oriented, et cetera.
Two broad but distinct models of power: one
largely based on Political Islam and the other
largely based on miltarist nationalism.
And here is how that has played out in Libya:
The side considered part of the 'militarist
nationalist' camp is the House of Representatives
and General Khalifa Haftar.
He leads what he calls the Libyan National
Army or LNA and is based in the eastern city
of Tobruk.
The LNA is supported by Russia, Saudi Arabia,
the UAE and Egypt.
Egypt shares a long border with Libya - and
sees Haftar and his LNA as the best way to
prevent extremist attacks spilling over that
border.
Along with the UAE and Saudi Arabia, Egypt
also sees Haftar as a bulwark against the
spread Islamic groups like the Muslim Brotherhood
- which they consider a terror organisation.
On the one hand, you have those regional and
international actors that have come to the
conclusion or to the idea that there's a need
for a strongman that could contribute to restore
authority.
And so for them, stability, authority and
even military authority are perceived as the
priority.
On the other side, you have the UN-recognised
Government of National Accord or GNA.
It is considered to be part of the 'political
Islam' camp, is led by Prime Minister Fayez
al-Sarraj and is based in the capital Tripoli.
The GNA’s international backers include
Qatar and Turkey.
Turkey wants drilling rights in the Mediterranean
but also has a shared ideological framework
with the GNA- namely political Islam and support
for the Muslim Brotherhood across the region.
The coalition that has brought together the
GNA, Turkey, Qatar represents an attempt to
bring together those forces that have opposed
military rule, some Islamist element.
And political Islam has also been an important
component, but not the only one.
You also have European countries like France
and Italy backing opposing sides, each saying
they want stability in the region.
But regardless of intention, all of this has
led to a feeling that this isn't really about
Libyans and their future.
Sometimes people question whether what we
have in Libya is actually a civil war or an
international war that's being fought on Libyan
soil and in Libyan skies.
The rivalry between the two administrations
reached a head in 2019 when Haftar tried but
failed to conquer Tripoli.
The country has been at a chaotic impasse
ever since.
International focus is often on Libya’s
fate as a battleground for regional proxy
warfare.
Many Libyan people feel they don’t have
a seat at the table.
We have now gotten to a point where what Libyans
think or what the aspirations of the Libyan
people are have become irrelevant because
of the level of foreign interference in this
country.
Meanwhile daily life in Libya is hard and
is getting worse.
I have family there.
I have friends there located on almost all
the geographic locations
I wouldn’t say that they want the same thing
institutionally speaking or that they have
the same views over legitimacy but mostly
what the Libyan people want is roughly what
every citizen in this world wants: good governance,
sustainable authorities, employment opportunities,
some freedom of expression.
They overthrew the regime before.
If neither of the two administrations which
claim legitimacy fail to improve their lives,
might the Libyan people have the courage to
challenge both of them?
We have seen some genuine videos of mothers,
of young people coming out on the streets
and airing these grievances deteriorating
living conditions, of insecurity, of young
people being taken to war or leaving the country
on boats to Europe.
This is an indication that people or the citizens
might have a certain threshold that if that
is crossed, then they will come out on the
streets.